Optics or the enhancement of our natural vision...
...has been one of the biggest catalysts for science....
...over the past 500 years.
Interestingly, it wasn't scientific interest...
...but more practical matters....
...that led to the initial advancements in optics....
...starting around 1440 when Johannes Gutenberg...
...invented his printing press.
In short order, books which had been a rarity,....
...were now becoming a widespread phenomenon.
All that new reading material...
...meant more knowledge was circulating.
But it also meant that more people were straining their eyes,...
...likely as they read by candlelight.
And while spectacles had been invented in Italy around 1286,...
...the need for reading glasses increased substantially.